and we're going to get everyone
uh that we can possibly uh evacuate
until the clock runs out or we run out
of capability and then we'll hope that
the taliban are nice and the taliban
will be nice so long as we pay them
american taxpayer dollars it is the most
mewling pathetic disreputable thing i've
ever seen in my life in terms of
american foreign policy and it is not
close
it's an absolute disaster in afghanistan
as far as getting people out the nato
secretary general said yesterday well
you know nato is telling the taliban we
expect them to provide safe passage this
is juns stoltenberg the nato secretary
general well as long as you guys are are
telling them that you expect them to
provide safe passage i'm sure the
taliban will do what you say or
alternatively the taliban now holds all
the cards
because the united states decided to
withdraw with no plan at all to even
protect the american citizens on the
ground the taliban hold all the cards
what happens if the taliban just say no
is the united states going to deploy
thousands of troops into kabul to go
house to house to find the american
citizens were there is that do you think
joe biden's going to do that
i don't
what's what are you gonna do
sanction the taliban they have no
economy
what exactly is the threat here you guys
just abandoned the place and then you're
like you better let out our guys why
would they do that the answer is they
would do that if we bribed them okay
that is the next step here the next step
is that the biden administration is
going to send pallets of cash to the
taliban and then biden is going to say
look how they moderated look at that
they moderated they let all of our
people out so really this isn't that bad
i handled this beautifully everybody got
out and then a few weeks later the
taliban will emerge from their caves to
explain that in fact they were given
billions of dollars by the biden
administration hundreds of millions of
dollars by the biden administration in
order to free what are essentially
american hostages now in afghanistan
and they will humiliate biden that is
how this is going to play out with like
75 certainty like anyway here's the nato
secretary general threatening with
nothing
our diplomats on the ground our people
on the ground are working uh hard to
enable those who are threatened those
who have worked for us staff and others
to enable them to get to the airport and
also sending a very clear message to
taliban that we expect them to provide
safe passage
to enable people to
get to the airport as of now it seems
like what you're saying is this depends
on the good graces of the taliban
we don't control the territory outside
the uh airport
so yes that's yes this is we are relying
on the good graces of the taliban the
taliban have no good graces the only
reason that they release the americans
here is if they're paid off
that is the only reason because what
exactly is joe biden going to do launch
a bunch of airstrikes into the
countryside
what exactly is nato going to do at this
point reoccupy
they're not going to do any of that
stuff and the taliban know it
you just surrendered the country to a
bunch of 8th century barbarian cavemen
and now you're like maybe they'll be
nice maybe by the way again joe biden is
saying they will be nice he's telling
george stephanopoulos maybe they'll
moderate
cia analyst matt zeller who's been on
cnn a lot he said here's what the
taliban's actually doing they're taking
people's passports in kabul so if you
show up with a passport to try and get
past the barricade and get into the
airport they'll just take your passport
from you
we need to basically tell the taliban
that they need to shut down their
checkpoints in the city because they're
actively taking people's passports i've
had u.s citizens who have had their u.s
passports taken from them their green
cards taken from them afghans are having
their documentation stolen from them by
the taliban an attempt to prevent them
from being able to even get into the air
base
okay meanwhile the secretary of defense
of the united states right the the most
powerful military presence in the
history of the world
he says he's asked about evacuating
americans and he can't guarantee that we
will keep troops in there for for long
enough to even evacuate americans
look at the way he's hedging his bets
here this is because this is reality
okay
when we say that we are going to
evacuate 10 to 15 000 americans there
are a bunch of americans who are out
there on the countryside they ain't
coming home
they're a bunch of americans in kabul
many of those people will not be coming
home
the biden administration knows this
because they blew it they blew it all
the way here is the defense secretary of
the united states of america talking
about how we cannot evacuate americans
thanks to a ragtag backwater group of
cavemen firing ak-47s
and who were just handed billions of
dollars in american military technology
by a surrendering american pusillanimous
president
this is this is so humiliating it's the
most humiliating thing i've ever seen in
my life with regard to american foreign
policy i mean it is not close
i think it may be the most humiliating
thing any american has ever seen in
their lifetime period and it took two
years for the united states too after
the united states large scale withdrawal
from vietnam it took about two years for
everything to collapse in vietnam this
took about five minutes
and now the united states is left
begging and pleading with the taliban to
evacuate american citizens here's the
defense secretary of the most powerful
military power in the history of the
world
saying
that you know we'll try and get people
out until the clock runs out by the way
when he says until the clock runs out
that is a tacit admission that we are
now working on the taliban's timetable
we're really working hard uh to get as
many people through
uh as possible and quite frankly we're
not we're
it's obvious we're not close to where we
want to be in terms of getting the
numbers through so we're going to work
that 24 hours a day seven days a week
and we're going to get everyone
that we can possibly uh evacuate
evacuate it and i'll do that as long as
we possibly can until the clock runs out
or we run out of capability
okay we'll do it until the clock runs
out or we run out of capability the are
you talking about the clock runs out
who's clock
who's clock there are only two players
in the scenario the taliban and biden
that's it
no other players so who's clock are we
talking about joe biden's artificial
timeline for getting out or are we now
talking about the fact that the taliban
has set a clock for the united states to
leave and joe biden is going to obey the
clock of again the worst people on
planet earth
these barbarians that's who we're going
to obey that's the or our military
capability runs out our military
capability we spend
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
every year on the united states military
our capability runs out for doing what
driving people to the airport in
defiance
of a rag-tag group of people
armed with like bicycle locks
like what what are you what the what are
you talking about what that's the
secretary of defense of the united that
guy needs it that guy needs to be out he
needs to he needs to resign frankly
biden should resign i mean he's not
going to obviously he's not going to be
impeached by a democratic congress
but if anybody had any stones they would
this is the most pathetic thing i've
ever seen in my life as an american
citizen
it is the most mewling pathetic
disreputable thing i've ever seen in my
life in terms of american foreign policy
and it is not close we saw a lot of crap
under barack obama
this is abjectly pathetic the state
department press secretary wendy sherman
was asked about this yesterday and she
says well no government could evacuate
all these citizens no one could really i
mean when you think about it it's really
hard well yeah it is hard when you get
rid of all the american troops that are
protecting all the air bases that
allowed people to leave yes that does
make it rather difficult does it not
maybe somebody should have conveyed that
to the president or maybe having
conveyed that to the president if he
insisted on going ahead with his plan
somebody should have resigned in protest
didn't we hear that a lot during the
trump administration if you hate it so
much you should leave well
well anyone bueller here's wendy sherman
kabul i don't know if you've ever been
there is an enormous city
enormous
and it has um
uh
in fact had more and more people come to
kabul because they thought it was the
safest place to be in afghanistan
so it is difficult under any
circumstances and i don't know of any
uh government that would be capable of
reaching out to where everybody might be
particularly those who have not signed
up to us to help them
which is why you shouldn't have
surrendered the city
lloyd austin doubled down on this the
secretary of defense says we don't have
the capacity to collect our people we
just don't we can't do it right so
originally what was funny about this
particular exchange is that mark milley
we'll get to in just one second the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
who's so concerned about white rage
white rage
it's really it's really fortunate we
have such geniuses running our military
establishment nobody gets fired for
losing wars around here it's pretty
impressive
what am i you want to talk about a
government make work program apparently
the joint chiefs of staff is one of them
so is the defense secretary ship
so so he started off this little
exchange mark mainly by saying this is a
political problem and then lloyd austin
jumps in to save the president he says
no it's not it's not a political problem
it's a capacity problem
i would draw a distinction bar between
extracting
uh
someone in an in extremist condition or
a circumstance versus going out and
collecting up large numbers of uh of
american citizens do you have the
capability to go out and collect
americans
we don't have the capability to go out
and collect up large numbers of of
people
we don't have the capability to collect
them okay you know what that capability
amounts to it amounts to literally you
drive a car where the citizen is you
pick them up in your car you bring them
back to the airport you're saying we
can't do that the reason they can't do
that is because the taliban have set up
checkpoints
and so what they're really afraid of is
that somebody will get into a shooting
fight with the taliban at the outskirts
of the airport and then the airport will
be overrun by the taliban that is the
fear the fear is that america will
attempt to deploy its forces into kabul
in order to pick up all the americans
and the taliban won't let them and then
you'll be in a shooting war and brad
doesn't want that because he doesn't
want to have to put troops back into
kabul and then have an urban fight with
the taliban in a city that he just
conceded so instead we'll just leave the
americans out there and then we'll hope
that the taliban are nice and the
taliban will be nice so long as we pay
them american taxpayer dollars so they
can continue to
propagate their
evil regime
of rape torture and tyranny
that's all that's happening here the
united states is now going to be the
chief funder of the taliban
that's what's going to happen we're
going to end up giving them the money
because how else we're going to get our
guys out and why exactly would they let
us get our guys out if that's the case
meanwhile joe biden had to be bullied by
george stephanopoulos into making a
commitment to leave american troops
there as long as necessary to get the
americans out by the way that's not
going to happen they're going to be
americans who get stuck in afghanistan
i'm just saying that's going to happen
right now and if it doesn't happen it's
because joe biden's going to bribe the
taliban
the commitment holes to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31st but if we don't
the troops will if they don't will
determine at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay we get them all out
oh my god
you see it's unbelievable how george
stephanopoulos has to walk him through
that right so he gives an answer and his
answer is basically we'll determine at
the end of the august 31st deadline
who's left
and stephanopous is like um what now
so you're saying that if they're america
if there are americans left we might
leave anyway
so he has to prompt biden until he gets
to the right answer there and
and
you just massage his ass until the
correct answer comes popping out of
there
so george george stephanopoulos is doing
here amazing stuff
okay but don't worry it's not just joe
biden who ought to resign and lloyd
austin our pathetic defense secretary
who ought to resign uh it's it's
american it's the entire infrastructure
the entire infrastructure ought to be
thrown out on their butts
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video